looking forward seeing you on the small  screen as you're very soon and what  advice would you give juror going back  into season four and what had been your  favorite moment sister oh so far my  advice to him would be just relaxed  don't push it you know take your time  try and judge the territory  don't don't don't give too much away but  he's quite wise he you know he he adores  her but he really values her as a leader  and think she has all the right  qualities to be successful and be a  benign ruler I like this sort of  one-on-one combat where I think it was  in the first season and it was a Khal  Drogo was dying in the tent and one of  his one of his cohorts tried to but had  turned against the Khaleesi we had this  sword fine I took him out I like that  yeah I got this karma through ok yeah  what is good  you